people of the internets hello and
welcome to another animal crossing video
retro rack and tour here and i will be
your guide today
as we venture down into the fossil area
of my museum
believe it or not guys my son and i have
finally completed
the fossils and to be honest with you we
didn't really trade i don't think i
trade or got any as gifts these have
been
all obtained by my son and i uh digging
well hello diana i didn't expect to see
you here
diana how you doing good to see you so i
thought what would make a fun
video is if i went through the entire
dinosaur area now that we have all the
fossils and tried to name
every single one of them without looking
it up
and we're starting right now
now before just so i prepare you guys
for this my son
is a big dinosaur buff so we read a lot
of dinosaur books
we'll see how i do with these here all
right so number one we have the
ophthalmosaurus
ophthalmosaurus right
right i mean that's got to be pretty
close plesiosaurus i do know that one i
know the palestiosaurus
archelon archelon archelon i think
archelon
archelon sounds good to me now i know
you guys
are going to let me know down in the
comments how many of these i mess up on
i thought you know i could look it up
and see what the correct pronunciation
is but it might be even better if i have
you guys correct me
down in the comments and let me know
what is actually the correct
pronunciation so let me know
how many of these i get correct right
here i believe we have the
quizzle coatless sounds pretty good to
me that's always that's how i pronounce
it in my son's books
pteranodon there we go that's an easy
one over here we have the stegosaurus
and then right below him this one is
a hotly contested one i feel like my son
and i
in the books that we've read have seen
several different pronunciations for
this one
from anki to ankh eye to ankle
so i'm just going to go with
ankylosaurus
almost like you know your ankle but i
have heard ankylosaurus and i've heard
ankylosaurus
i'm just gonna say ankylosaurus and hope
that me
settling there in the middle is gonna be
the correct one
and just to the right of him we have the
iguanodon that was pretty easy
to do right there and also the
parasaurolophus
i think i think parasaur parasar
i think it's parasaur oh now this one
i'm not even joking with you guys my
six-year-old actually at the time he was
five years old when he told me how to
pronounce this i was trying to sound it
out in a book that i was reading to him
i was like
pat peck and he's like dead
pachycephalosaurus i said what
so i do know this one pachycephalosaurus
let's go triceratops of course of course
we know
the famous triceratops and then moving
over to the right here
even more of the most famous dinosaurs
of all spinosaurus right
here and then below him we have the
copper light which my son and i learned
on the last video that we did
if you haven't seen that one check it
out i'll include a little card up to it
here in the top corner of your screen
but it is a fossilized
dung of a dinosaur i kid you not guys
i kid you not look it up if you don't
believe me dinosaur track right here and
then the fearsome t-rex or
tyrannosaurus rex as we know him over
here on the right side now we have
ooh now this one i have not pronounced
this one in a while or seen it in any of
the books that we've been reading
dionycus
day nanakus i'm going to say day nanicus
daenercus sounds right to me right
that's it that's it
come on now if you're wondering what
this is it took me forever
to figure this out i looked at this and
i'm just like what the heck is going on
here is this like some kind of like
orange or onion and then it hit me it is
actually a meteorite uh that
that you know scientists believe killed
the dinosaurs we had the big meteor hit
and then the dust cloud and then the
dinosaurs couldn't get food and that's
how they went extinct so
if you were wondering what that is guys
that is actually what that's supposed to
be
right here we have dimetrodon and then
just to the right of him the
jeremiah jeremiah
jeremiah i'm going to say jeremiah
in the center of the room we have two of
the largest dinosaurs diplodocus
right here and then just behind him
we've got
the brachiosaurus all right guys let me
know how am i doing so far
i feel like i'm i'm at about a 85
percent maybe 90
correction rate right now we'll see how
it goes here in the final room now these
aren't technically dinosaurs but these
are all
prehistoric creatures that have been
added to this section so we'll go
through these here as well
right here we have the mammoth very
famous one right there not too hard to
pronounce
same thing for this guy right here the
saber-tooth tiger
now these other ones i had to look these
up as we were collecting these fossils
because it had been a long time since i
had heard of the mega syrups here i
think that's correct
mega syrups and then also the
megalosaurus just to the right of him
and then here in the back we have the
australopeth
australopith i've always wondered what
exactly is the point of this up here is
it just for you to see how tall you
are in relation to the villagers of
animal crossing i guess that's the main
purpose of it here
now if you've never been upstairs in the
dinosaur area of the museum
to be honest with you i'm not really
sure what this is here for maybe they're
going to expand it in the future
i know that it does give you a slightly
different view of the dinosaurs here so
if you want to get a little
more overhead view gonna get a nice shot
right there
of the t-rex and the triceratops and
then if we just keep going to the left
you'll see that there's
nothing extra up here by going up these
stairs but it does give you just a
little bit of a different
view of the dinosaur area ah you thought
we're done but
not so fast we can't forget about the
first room that you find as you make
your way down
into the dinosaur area so we'll just
start right here oh man
this may be this may be the toughest
room of them all acanthus
acanthostega acanthostega
i'm confident with that one shark tooth
pattern okay more confident on that one
i admit
over here on the left side we have the
ammonite and also
amber every time i see amber all i can
think of is jurassic park
trilobite hello buddy anomalocaris
anomalocaris i'm saying that
with confidence except not really
[Music]
oh my goodness i don't even remember
donating this one what in the world okay
hold on let's let's let's
really focus here guys let's see okay we
got
m-y-l-l-o-k-u-n
ninja ninja so i feel like it ends with
kun kun miji kun minjia
that is my final answer that was bad
that was way wrong
dunkley osteous dunkleosteus
dunkle yeah it looks like dunkleosteus
dunkolostius that's what i'm going with
and then we have the
eusthenopterin
eustanopterin am i done yet oh yes thank
goodness
but wait retro i can hear you guys now
you forgot one
and you're right it wasn't until a few
days after recording this guys that i
actually discovered i still lacked one
more fossil it's all good though because
now i have it and here's my attempt at
pronouncing it
the archaeopteryx no i didn't look it up
i promise i did not look it up
archaeopteryx see pretty good right all
right guys
if you enjoyed this and had a good time
and want to see more videos like this
make sure you hit that subscribe button
before
you go maybe we'll have to go through
the fish area and do this once we
complete that
maybe a while before we complete that
one but hey we could go through and try
to pronounce the ones that we do have
maybe even the bugs as well that's gonna
be it for me today i will talk to you
again soon